♪ ♪
>> Greg: ONE THING WAS CLEAR
ABOUT THE ELECTION, WE KNOW WHO
THE LOSERS ARE, THE POLLSTERS
AND THE MEDIA, THE CANNIBAL
TWINS WHO FEED OFF OF EACH
OTHER’S MANUFACTURED
DISSOLUTIONS.
IT WORKS LIKE THIS.
FOR THE CANDIDATE AND SUPPORT
ARE AS RACIST, THAT SILENCES THE
VOTERS SO THE POLLS REFLECT THE
EXTERIOR.
WHY WOULD YOU TELL THE TRUTH TO
STRANGERS.
AND RIOTS ENSUE ANOTHER
CONFIDENCE OF THE SMEAR AS
THOUGH AMERICA DESERVES IT UNDER
TRUMP.
EVEN THOUGH THEY STUCK THE EVIL
WHITE MAN TAG LEFT IN THE
ELECTION AMONG LATINOS, BLACK
MEN, BLACK WOMEN, AGAIN IF HE IS
RACIST, HE SUCKS AT IT.
HE IS NO JOY REID.
>> IF SOMEHOW THEY MANAGED TO
STUMBLE INTO THE SUPREME COURT,
DO ANY OF YOU GUYS TRUST
CLARENCE AND AMY CONEY BARRETT
AND THOSE GUYS TO ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THE LETTER OF THE LAW?
NO.
>> Greg: SO THERE WAS THAT.
IT SHOULD PISS  OFF.
EVERY HATEFUL SMEAR FOUNDED
SHADE.
IMAGINE HOW MANY MORE BLACKS,
LATINOS, AND WHITES WOULD HAVE
VOTED IF THE MEDIA TOOK AND
ASKED TO THAT POLL, WHICH IS WHY
THEY DIDN’T.
AND SPEAKING OF POLLS COMING
WANT TO KNOW WHY NOBODY TRUSTS
THE OUTCOME INCLUDING TRUMP?
WHEN YOU KEEP BEING LIED TO, HOW
CAN YOU TRUST ANYONE?
AND WHAT ARE POLLSTERS ASKED,
HOW CAN YOU GO TO BED SEEN ONE
RESULT AND THEN WAKE UP WITH A
NEW ONE AND NOT BE A LITTLE
SUSPICIOUS.
SO DON’T BLAME TRUMP, BLAME THE
MEDIA/POSTERIOR INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX.
IT IS UNKIND TO SNAKES AND
SALESMEN, BECAUSE WHATEVER THE
MEDIA POLLSTERS ARE SELLING,
NOBODY IS GOING TO BUY IT EVER
AGAIN.
I SAID THAT IN 2016, JESSE.
SO I WAS WRONG THEN.
ARE PEOPLE IN NORMAL JOBS AS
WRONG AS POLLSTERS, THEY WOULD
BE OUT OF A JOB.
>> Jesse: IN FOUR MORE YEARS.
DID A LITTLE
ANALYSIS AND I KNOW WHO YOU ARE
OUT THERE.
I MIGHT NAME SOME NAMES ON
SATURDAYS NIGHT ON "WATTERS’
WORLD."
BECAUSE TRUST ME.
IF YOU HAVE ONE DESIGNED TO
SUPPRESS SUPPORTERS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A SAMPLE OF 49% DEMOCRATS
IN THAT POLE, THE PRESIDENT WILL
NEVER DO WELL THAT IS HALF
SAMPLED WITH DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE THAT IS DESIGNED TO
THINK FROM WISCONSIN AND THEY
SEEN NEWS IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AND
DONALD TRUMP LOSING BY 17
POINTS.
YOU SAY WHY DO I NEED TO, IT IS
A FOREGONE CONCLUSION.
AND NOT JUST THE POLLING
INDUSTRY, THE MEDIA AND A
LANDSLIDE VICTORY.
IN NINE OR 10%, NO, IT WAS 2-3%.
SO AGAIN THE LAST TWO ELECTIONS
WERE WRONG AND CORONAVIRUS
WRONG, THE RUSSIA HOAX.
AND THEN THEY COVERED UP FOR THE
BIG GUY RIGHT AT THE HOME
STRETCH.
YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
DAMAGE THAT DID.
BUT WE WILL NEVER FIND OUT.
>> Greg: IF THEY ARE PUTTING
THE THUMB ON THE SCALE.
ARE THEY DOING IT BY ACCIDENT
AND THEY DON’T KNOW THEY ARE
DOING IT?
>> Dana: I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
AUTOPSY OF THAT.
>> Greg: WE HAVE TO KILL THEM
FIRST, YOU KNOW.
>> Dana: I LOOK AT THE SOCIAL
SCIENCE THAT WE HAVE.
IT DOESN’T NEED TO BE REVISITED?
PERHAPS.
49% DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THERE ARE
THAT MANY IN THE DIVISION.
I DON’T KNOW, I THINK THAT IT
HAS A LOT OF THE MOVEMENT TO
DEAL, BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
EVERYBODY KEEP IN MIND, LOOK AT
THE AVERAGE, DON’T JUST TAKE
ONE, TAKE A LOOK AT THE AVERAGE
AND IF YOU LOOK AT TOM BEVAN WHO
RUNS REAL QUICK POLITICS,
PENNSYLVANIA HAD IT ONE POINT UP
AT THE END.
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
>> Jesse: THE ONLY REASON THAT
CAME IN WAS BECAUSE THE LAST
WEEK WITH THE INSIDER, AND PUT
IT THROUGH.
AND THAT REALLY NARROWS THE GAP.
>> Dana: AGAIN, THAT’S WHY, I
TRY TO LOOKK AT THE AVERAGE AND
DON’T THINK THE OUTCOME IS
ENTIRELY UNBELIEVABLE AT THIS
POINT.
BUT I DO THINK ALSO THE OTHER
THING ABOUT THE MEDIA IS THAT
THERE WAS THIS RUMOR THAT THIS
INFORMATION WAS THE REASON THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS WINNING IN
MIAMI, DAYTON COUNTY, AND NOT
THE FACT THAT HE HAD ACTUALLY
WORKED HIS TAIL OFF AND THAT YOU
HAVE LATINOS FOR TRUMP, CUBANS
FOR TRUMP.
AND AL SHARPTON SAID THAT
CUBAN-AMERICANS ARE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO PROPAGANDA ABOUT SOCIALISM.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BE?
BECAUSE THEY PLED SOCIALISM.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THE FACT OF THE SHY VOTER
SYNDROME, IS THERE ANY WAY
PEOPLE CAN FIGURE THAT OUT?
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK THAT
THEY WERE SO MANY SHY, YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT WERE NECESSARY PART
OF THE VOTER POLE THAT COULD’VE
COME OUT.
AND DRAWN OUT TO NEW PEOPLE.
WE SAID IN RECORD OF TURNOUT
YESTERDAY FOR REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
IT WAS AMAZING HOW MANY PEOPLE
VOTED YESTERDAY.
IT’S GOOD NEWS.
TO YOUR POINT THERE WAS NO BLUE
WAVE, AND YOU SAW SOME OF THEM
SAYING THAT THAT WAS GOING TO BE
A POSSIBILITY.
AND IT DID NOT HAPPEN.
AND I AGREE WITH DANA PERINO.
AND THEY WERE ON TARGET SAYING
THAT THERE WOULD BE A BLUE WAVE
AND THERE WAS IN 2018.
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
I ALSO THINK, HOW COME YOU GUYS
ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT I TALK TO, THE PEOPLE IN
THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN SIDE, THEY
THOUGHT HOUSE REPUBLICANS WERE
GOING TO HAVE A BAD NIGHT.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE NEXT
SLIDE.
>> Juan: I KNOW, BUT YOU
LISTEN THERE PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE
ARE GOING TO WIN THE SENATE, WIN
AND WIN, WIN.
>> Jesse: THEY KEPT THE
SENATE, DINNER TODAY DIDN’T THEY
THEY?
>> Dana: MICHAEL MOORE IS THE
BEST POLLSTER AROUND.
THEY TAKE IT IN HOUSE AND MAYBE
GO DOWN ANOTHER POINT.
HE HAS HAD A PRETTY GOOD READ ON
THE WAY THINGS ARE GOING.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT WE SEE
IS WE LOOK AT THE POPULAR VOTE
AND HOW VERY CLOSE IT IS.
AND WAKE UP AND SEE THE REALITY
OF THE OTHER SIDE.
THERE IS HALF OF AMERICA VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS POLICIES.
AND THE MEDIA AND THE POLLSTERS
NEED TO FIND A WAY TO REACH
THESE PEOPLE.
NO ONE WILL PAY ATTENTION THE
NEXT TIME AROUND.